ah
my name is Sergey vysotsky and the
member ukrainian parliament and I've
been to mind dying from the first to the
last day for me the processes that we
encounter at Maidan were much the same
that Europe in conference in now some
age of the great European revolutions
was all about gaining her rights and
about not becoming the part of this new
hybrid post Soviet empire I should try
to build basically it was about European
integration and it was about integrated
not to the European Union itself maybe
but to this this room of the European
values one every person matters one each
life is matters it was a small square of
European values in this for Soviet
authoritarian system that we encountered
during any college times they came from
all the cities of Ukraine from dunya is
from Crimea and I saw like some elderly
people that came to my damn they were
worried poo they weren't as such you
know socially active but they tried to
help and I saw some guys in this luxury
cars mercedes and range rovers and
bentleys and they too could some
products and came to my damn just gave a
gave it away and then stood here because
it was all about freedom